it's great to be joined today by Neil
Patel who is an advisor to kind ads
which is working on really a number of
the different issues that relate to
advertising that the David Pakman show
has been dealing with we've talked about
how creators of content have been
affected by online ad problems like
YouTube's at pocalypse we've talked
about just really not good fits between
our audience and advertisers that have
approached us we've also talked about
how ads impact the user experience so
I'm sort of curious Neil to begin with
is there a particular one of these
problems I mentioned or others that I
didn't mention that was like the entry
point for what kind ads is looking to do
yeah you got it right
so publishers have a lot of irrelevant
ads on their website advertisers are
paying an arm and a leg because in the
middle man's keeping majority of the
money and users and consumers of the web
their data is being used everywhere and
they're not even getting compensated for
it nor are they even in control of their
data where they can say no you can't use
it or yes you can't use the user data
thing is interesting to me because
there's a bit of a not necessarily a
double standard but there's a bit of a
contradiction that I sometimes hear from
users of social media and web sites like
YouTube and others which is on the one
hand they get agitated irritated or
upset when there are ads that they're
seeing that are irrelevant to them but
at the same time
when the ads are super relevant because
of the way that their data is being used
they're also kind of understandably
freaked out and concerned about that
along privacy lines so can you talk a
little bit about what whether that is or
isn't a contradiction and sort of how we
might deal with that problem yeah it is
a contradiction because users only want
to see relevant stuff yet they don't
want people to show um irrelevance top
right like they want relevant ads yet
they don't want people using their data
to show them relevant ads and it's kind
of hard because without that you can't
really showcase relevant ads and there's
two ways to solve it one is you can just
disclose to the users and get them to
agree upon it but - and this one's
actually easier
to solve this problem is it's actually
really easy to show a user relevant ads
without using any of the personal data
based on the website they're on for
example if you're on the health and
fitness website that's talking about
supplements you know becoming stronger
putting on some weight gaining some
muscles getting ripped sure and they
show you ads for products related to you
know those things and helping you get
ripped and muscular and putting on ten
pounds of muscle
you don't really have an issue and you
don't really need much data from the
user any you know because that page is
all about becoming or bulking up so and
if you look at kind their goal isn't to
follow you around the web and show you
more relevant ads by following you
around and using your data it's more so
when you're on a fitness website you
should be seeing relevant Fitness ads
and more specifically you shouldn't just
be seeing ads for fitness products you
should be seeing ads for stuff that the
person who's writing the article who
owns the website truly believes in right
because it's like if you're a fitness
celebrity you have this huge following
and you yourself are only willing to use
a few supplements because you know they
were why would you want to promote other
supplements that you don't believe in
just because someone's paying you right
and it seems like the theme is sort of
that in many cases it's the middleman
that is creating either the sort of bad
feeling about how one's data is being
used to follow them around the web or
there's a middle man who's interjecting
irrelevant ads that you don't want to
see so like is the direct relationship
between content provider and advertiser
and user sort of what what might help to
solve this problem correct and if you
think of it this way if a user could
control the type of ads that are beating
this or if the publisher can control the
type of ads that are shown on their
website you have a lot less problems but
right now through most ad networks you
can you just put a JavaScript in and
then you're off to the races and
whatever as they want to show they show
you you don't have any control over that
because these middlemen are optimizing
for revenue they're not optimizing for
the experience
a publisher doesn't want crap ads on
their site they don't want to ruin the
user experience they care about their
website it's their baby the user doesn't
want to be bombarded all day long the
advertiser wants a relevant audience who
believes in their products or services
and on top of that they don't want to
pay outrageous amounts so when you start
connecting the people together
advertisers and publishers and you let
them talk not only are they able to do
more creative ad campaigns that are
customized to you that end user so it's
more relevant to you but also the
publisher makes more money and the
advertiser gets a better rate because
you're cutting out the middlemen and
then they can do more custom creative
stuff versus just displaying regular old
ads that most people ignore so talk
about how the end-user publisher and
advertiser interact with the kind ad
system like in the simplest possible
terms and then maybe we'll dig into each
of them a little bit the publisher signs
up you can go to kind ads do sign up
verified that it's your website and you
can say I'm interested in just putting
ads on my site through emails or push
notifications you select the medium you
select what you want for it and then
advertiser sign up and they can reach
out to you and then they can tell you
what specific campaigns they want you
negotiate and you either close a deal or
you don't and as for the user they can
come to the site share their personal
data and they can get compensated for it
if they don't want to share their data
or they don't want to see ads they don't
have to either
so we'll get to the compensation I think
sort of through this next question and
for me this is like one of the key
questions that I'm asking frequently
when I talk to any project that's either
developing on the blockchain or doing an
ICO which is why is this better served
by being on the blockchain
and why is a token useful sure a few
reasons so token makes it I'll answer
the token one first token makes it
really simple for people to deal with
advice typically when you're dealing
with USD and different currencies it's
really hard so for example kind mainly
focuses on english-language ads right
now I do know they have plans to expand
into other lis
which is but it's hard to transfer money
between countries like it's very
difficult to give you a very terrible
example but it'll work is I spoke at
Vietnam a conference that our marketing
and when I speak our comps as I get paid
anywhere from like 25 grand on the
really low-end 52 months and they kept
showing it to me and like it just took
them months to get me the money right
just because it's a pain people have the
same problems when they're dealing with
ads it's not easy to get the money
across different countries there's a lot
of people that say in India who have
businesses that are focused on the US
right and there's a lot of people
focusing on the English markets but the
country that they live in isn't based on
USD or the Canadian dollar or you know
pounds or euros or whatever it may be
now going back to your question on the
blockchain there's a few reasons one you
don't have a big company who's
controlling all the data to you're able
to cut out the middleman and three best
of all by having it decentralized you
can have a very clean ledger and here's
what I mean by this in advertising you
have issues of click fraud and
publishers manipulating their data and
advertisers manipulating things but have
you decentralized it makes it harder for
people to manipulate the data and screw
it all up and be like yeah we're a great
website and a resource pay us you know a
thousand tokens or a million tokens to
advertise here when it's really crap but
they're able to manipulate the data and
make them look great even though they're
not and is the way the system is
designed one where you both are as an
advertiser buying ads using the token
and as a publisher being paid out in
that same token correct and how does
kind ads make money is it transaction
fees on those deals no it doesn't make
money the goal is not to make money the
goal is to disrupt the advertising
ecosystem so it's actually it's
organized as a not not in a legal sense
a nonprofit but there is not actually in
other words the play is won
of market share and reduction and
friction that exists in other sort of AD
relationships but not one where it's to
skim transaction fees off of each deal
correct the goal of kind is to
democratize the Internet so by trying to
do all of this the goal isn't to make
money it's to democratize it right cut
out the middleman cut out the big
players who are worth hundreds of
billions of dollars make it better for
advertisers make it better for
publishers who are producing the content
make it better for users who are
browsing the web and seeing ads and you
know people are using their data for
malicious purposes like the internet
needs to be kinder so in order in order
to work right is it is market share
really the issue is it having enough
advertisers buying ads publishers using
those or working with those advertisers
and then users who are in the ecosystem
correct yes
you don't need the users as much to
participate and share their data you
more so need the advertisers and
publishers and they already have a good
start on both last thing I'd like to
talk about on the token side before we
talk about the ico is the reward pool
right for the end users talk a little
bit about so you talked about a user
connects with the system and inputs
their data
what sort of choice what degree of
choice does a user have in terms of how
and how much of their data is shared and
how does that relate to their sort of
reward potential in the ecosystem yeah
it's uh
they have full control so if they don't
want any of their data shared they don't
have to if they don't want to see ads
they don't have to you're not gonna get
any tokens but they have full control
over on the flipside if they want to
share all their data and they want to
see ads you know wherever kind of
serving ads they can and you know
they'll get compensated for it talks
about ya know got it pretty much is up
to the user over anyone right like they
can decide if they want it or they don't
and it's more like black and white
versus okay if you share this you'll get
50 percent more tokens versus if you
don't share this you'll get 20 percent
less it's more so you either share it
all or you don't can you talk a little
bit about the
touken sale stages process etc there was
no public
iceo so it's just it was all the way
kind of coming about is there was a lot
of people like advertisers who wanted to
buy ads and they believed in the vision
and there was a lot of publishers that
you know the founders already had access
to and I knew some of them and something
is just connecting it all and making it
you know all in one centralized place
we've talked to some other projects that
have also skipped a public sale of any
kind and it seems to be I mean there
seems to be more of I don't know if I'm
generalizing but it seems that when
there's a sort of social or disruptive
mission that I'm more frequently seeing
the skipping of the public sale in it it
might be too small of a sample size to
really make make that generalization but
what's your sense of that yeah what
we're seeing or what I'm seeing is when
people are really trying to disrupt and
trying to do something big it's very
easy for them to skip the public sale
when they don't have a lot going on it
makes it much harder like if you look at
the kind project like the product is up
and running people can go and sign up
and use it a lot of people are doing
public sales because they don't have a
lot to show they haven't figured out the
model yet and they're just like yeah how
can I just get some quick cash it you
think it's that straightforward I mean
it's it's just a question of is do we
need cash and how can we get it yeah it
could also be in which some people just
want cash and we'll take whatever
possible right like some people will do
a public private whatever they want just
because they want the cash and then some
projects are doing it where hey we're
not interested in cash we're looking for
our users to help us grow the community
and you know whatever it may be
participate or however they want to end
up structuring it but I'm seeing
projects doing a bit of everything right
now it just really depends on how much
traction they have how big is their idea
and do they have people who believe in
their vision bigger picture
and this gets away a little bit from
kind ads do you believe that over the
next I don't know year or two years or
some some period of a couple of years
from now eighteen months something like
that are we going to see a sort of
smoothing out of the blockchain and ICO
world where there starts to be a sort of
more consistent pattern in how projects
are coming about being organized and
they're sort of respective timelines or
do you think that there's going to
continue to be this sort of not
literally Wild West type of type of
circumstance but just drastic variation
in both sort of quality scope and an
organization that we're seeing now I
think you'll start seeing it within one
to two years the reason being is you're
also starting to see a lot of big
players move in right Facebook just took
one of their head people and made them
in charge of blockchain initiatives now
they didn't say this is this is what
we're gonna do it's just that person is
in charge of figuring out blockchain and
figuring out how Facebook is a large
company could be leveraging it and I bet
you there's so many other large
corporations like the Google's of the
world the Microsoft of the world who
don't talk much about it but are also
doing the same thing it's too big to
ignore when you start seeing these
bigger players enter they're gonna start
I wouldn't say necessarily making the
projects better but they'll have some
sort of quality control people will
start getting used to what they're
seeing and they'll be like a minimum
threshold and like hey this is how
projects should be done here's the
processes here's the timelines and how
this is how it looks like
and you already starting to seem a bit
more of that you know if you go back to
mid 2017 compared to now it was really
crazy back then compared to what it is
now things are much more organized
they're better you're seeing a lot less
scammy projects coming about and it's
still not perfect but I would say within
the next year or two years they'll get
much better than what it is right now
we've been speaking with neil patel he's
an advisor to kind ads you can learn
more about kind ads using the links in
the video description neil really a
pleasure speaking with you thank you
thanks for having me